welcome to bit by bit a series where we
highlight one thing you can do to
optimize and potentially run a bit
better in Google Cloud today's topic IP
address management it's not always easy
and it's not always fun but we always
want to make sure we use our Network
space efficiently in gke standard one
way to do that is by configuring the
maximum number of PODS per node to
effectively get smaller pod ciders on
nodes so let's get to it
foreign
so start out with the GK standard
cluster that has only three nodes and
you can see here it's set to my current
context and my cubeconfig
and so we know that in kubernetes every
pod gets a unique IP address
below this implementation and the way
that it gets this IP address is that
each node in the cluster gets a cider
block from which it can assign Network
identities to the pods that it runs so
we can demonstrate that pretty quickly
we're going to describe the nodes in our
cluster and grep for pod ciders
okay so we can see here that we have
three nodes and so we get three ranges
back from describing all of our nodes in
our cluster and if we quickly run a pod
and grep for its IP we can see that it
gets an IP address from one of these
blocks because this is uh getting its IP
from the node that it runs on
if we grew up for IP then we can see
from the 10.44.2 Block that we now get
our
our pods IP address
so this is so far so good uh until we
begin to run the math
so we can see the address blocks for
each node listed here and
each of them is a slash 24 and that's
256 IP addresses
so by default GK standard clusters and
the respective node pools default to 110
maximum pods per node if you never tweak
that value
and some of this is for buffer needed in
case of iPod churn rates as pods come
and go but you could end up stranding a
lot of IP addresses in the long run if
you don't tune Max pods per node so
we're going to create a new node pool
here but instead we're going to set it
to 50 pods per node for Max pods per
node and we'll see that we immediately
get a smaller range for nodes in this
node pool a slash 25.
if you jump over to the documentation
you can see here that as you tweak the
max pods per node you'll get a different
cider block allocated for pods on that
node and you can see how that correlates
to the number of IP addresses and the
thing about this here is that this now
begins to become a planning exercise
where you understand roughly you know
what types of resources will be running
on certain node pools and node types and
will they run out of CPU and memory
before they run out of IP addresses in
terms of how many pods can fit on that
node
so we're going to let this node pool
create now we'll just take a second
now that that node pool has completed
creation we can see we've added nine
nodes to our cluster these are all in
pool one and they're ready to go and
keep in mind that these smaller ranges
when you tune maximum pods per node it's
also pulling from the same pod IP
address range that the whole cluster
gets it's just allocating them to each
node more sparingly when Max pods per
node value is set we're just going to do
a quick check that this worked we're
going to run the same command and grab
for pod ciders as we describe our nodes
we'll see the original Three nodes that
we had with Slash 24s but we can now see
that all the nodes that we added
afterwards had a slash 25 thus you know
preserving the IP address space that we
have for the pods in our cluster and our
overall Network topology
Network space is finite and for many
users gke isn't the only part of that
Network
so in your GK standard clusters consider
reducing the maximum number of PODS per
node to make sure that you can preserve
more IP addresses
as always you can learn more in the
links in the description below and we'll
see you in a bit
[Music]